now
boom what did you find this guy
give me a break P hey I only work with
professionals
speaking of which make sure the sound is
right this time I don't want to repeat
of Amarillo that was two [ __ ] years
ago
I don't do ADR this new guy
I'm not feeling it again just don't be
surprised if we have to make a change
new plan we do a walk through the inside
first then we shoot the intro just like
we always do just try to say the show's
name this time okay no problem
tonight on sewer Gators another
worthless [ __ ] shell happy ecstatic
are we rolling hey let's go get out of
the way it's locked after you so why are
we in hell this time
do you ever prep what's the preps shitty
house wookie sounds who is it haunted
[ __ ] me
how was it anchor you know we can sub
people not anchor what's that
nothing what's the story Andrey
abandoned farmhouse missing family foul
play suspected the usual how long do you
say this place has been abandoned three
years klancy get a shot of this let's
make a great cut away so uh hillbilly
Joe and his family go missing not
hillbillies the baker's jack and
Marguerite Baker and they were quiet not
backward a lot of bad rumors about their
son Lucas bad seed apparently [ __ ] no I
should have wore my good shoes oh [ __ ]
glad I had my shots although is to make
a great backdrop ah Dre what do you
think
Adri Andre Andre Clancy you see where
Andre wins where is he on [ __ ]
believable this is the last time I work
with that guy
I mean producers they come and go but a
good cameraman like you Clancy you stick
with me what the [ __ ] was that did you
hear that
Andre the [ __ ] is he
Adri were you man
what the hell you gotta be [ __ ]
kidding me
alright New Deal we find Andre and we go
I mean [ __ ] this show
you first
need a nice hero shot of me coming down
the ladder so
what do you see what is it
welcome to the family we gotta get
you
you